quartier sainte madeleine à strasbourg
depuis quelques mois 9 10 a pignon sur
rue neuve this la déesse égyptienne
gardienne des tombeaux ici on affiche la
couleur noire
le maître des lieux frédéric née fin des
années 70 en même temps que le mouvement
got son code vestimentaire il en a fait
sa spécialité
alors il ya les grands classiques et
puis les petites nouveautés
voilà une robe pour gothique romantique
ben voilà donc les cyber gotti qu'ils
aiment bien la couleur il met des corses
et le rose depuis tout petit j'ai
toujours adoré ce milieu gothic metal la
musique les vêtements c'est un habit qui
est il me plaît vraiment le plus je
trouve ça vraiment le plus beau qu'un
habit traditionnel ou en jogging nous
nous sommes vus comme ça quand régine
comme ça chez eux le
gothique dans l'attitude gothique dans
la tête principaux centres d'intérêts
musique littérature goût du romantisme
tendance à souligner le côté obscur de
la vie et pour le vérifier nous sommes
allés au rendez-vous dégote comme tous
les dimanches soir dj holy-dis reçoit 30
ans de gothisme cela n'est plus une
crise d'adolescence et c'est donc à lui
que nous avons posé la question
[Musique]
qu'est ce que ces quatre got aujourd'hui
qu'est ce que c'est être gothique
aujourd'hui comment dire ça la coupe est
une question vaste bien trop vaste car
le hic c'est que les gothiques ont fait
des petits le mouvement rassemble
aujourd'hui plusieurs dizaines de
courant de tangage de nuance cependant
une chose est sûre les clichés ont la
peau dure on nous traite comme des
satanique quoi alors comment on n'a rien
à voir avec le satanisme ça faut
vraiment se mettre ça une fois pour
toutes dans la tête le gothique c'est
romantique malgré que d'autres musiques
soit sombre lugubre qui fait peut-être
peur on est très joyeux
ce soir ambiance batcave du nom d'un
club londonien mener ce genre musical
dans les années 80 par franchement
sombre juste mélancolique que c'est
toujours le même comme qui revient ça
parle de la nature ça parle de d'efforts
et ça parle d'un univers ses tresses et
de l' aventure pour moi la musique
gothique sais je me vois plongé dans une
ruine voilà dans une ruine du château
certains ont déjà enterré le mouvement
got un courant sur le déclin du temps
pourtant des jeunes sont d'assurer la
relève ambrosia par exemple une lycéenne
la jeune fille passe un bac littéraire
son allure reflète aussi sans
philosophie
cette personne non durable c'est à lui
n'a aucun
suisse entend cimetière c'est la mort
c'est aussi le sujet pessimiste c'est
faux pas en parler maintenant pourquoi
il faudrait pas en parler ou est ce
qu'il faudrait pas l'arborer copains on
peut pas distinguer la vie de la mort on
ne peut pas enlever tout ce qui est
morbide tout ce qui est glauque au
contraire ça fait partie de la vie il
faut l'accepter avec c'est pour ça que
la vie est belle étrange paradoxe d'une
jeune fille toute vêtue de noir mais qui
voit l'avenir en rose c'est vrai cela
peut laisser songeur
[Musique]